moi je l'adoré je vais vous raconter une
anecdote parce que qu'ils gagnent il n'a
pas du tout la grosse tête il m'est
arrivé de faire des soirées voilà avec
les joueurs de l'équipe de france qu'ils
avaient des intrus café thé et c'est
vrai que quand il
avait un truc la fédé comme toulon et
c'est vrai que qu'il y avait un truc à
péter vous les ânes organisation je vais
vous dire la vérité et c'est vrai que
kilian je l'aï vu dans la soirée c'est
lui qui organise et c'est pousser les
tables indoor voilà s'est il demandé à
quelques si on voulait boire quelque
chose c'est un mec qui se prend pas du
tout la tête et moi y'a un truc qui m'a
marqué il m'a dit maniant il m'a dit
vrai c'est moi qui ai demandé au coach
si on pouvait sortir ce soir et s'ils
m'avaient dit non serait pas sorti mais
bon il m'a dit d'accord allez tu peux y
aller ce soir et tout franchement c'est
un garçon mais je vous jure une humilité
une gentillesse je l adore voilà et il
mérite et il est tellement dans son truc
ça veut dire que quand vous lui parlez
il peut vous parler tout mais il est
dans son match il est dans sa vie il est
c'est voilà c'est sa passion et c'est un
vrai passionné c'est un vrai bosseur il
bosse à fond je veux dire il est là tous
les jours à l'entraînement à l'heure il
déconne pas il sait pas le beau et c'est
pas la star c'est un truc de fou donc
voilà je pense que c'est mérité qu'ils
soient aujourd'hui pour moi le meilleur
joueur du monde je pense we were
raconter une petite anecdote sur sa
générosité si vous le permettez parce
que un jour il a fait la couverture de
time magazine qui est célèbre dans le
monde entier et sa maman a eu l'idée en
voyant ce en lui disant mais c'est vrai
que tu as une dimension planétaire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on créerait pas une
association qui l'a créé une association
inspired by qalqilya même ap et il ya
quatre-vingt dix-huit enfants 98 comme
son année de naissance et comme l'année
de la paix sa victoire en coupe du monde
de bondy et d'ailleurs qui bénéficient
d'un encadrement complet soutien
scolaire cours particuliers séjour au
ski week-end avec l'aide d'un groupe
hôtelier sponsor du psg je vais pas
donner le nom des locaux et voilà 98
enfant qui va accompagner de 12 à 20 ans
pour qu'ils grandissent qui mûrissent
qui réalisent leur rêve c'est beau quand
même pas une star comme les franchement
c'est celle-là ça c'est un fait
et je voudrais dire et je vous jure que
les gars de l'équipe de france sont des
mecs luc hernandez c'est un amour de
mecs son frère aussi antoine griezmann
c'est une banque c'est que des mecs
vraiment hyper gentil moyens aussi que
j'adore il faudrait que donc on a dit
ici la mission qui est un des plus
drôles de l'équipe c'est benjamin pava
est extraordinaire voilà et c'est vrai
qu'ils se prennent pas la tête ils sont
vraiment et même pays et careem carim
c'est un amour de mai qu'il benzema et
c'est vrai que hier ils ont fait jouer
il était karimi revenait de blessure et
c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir de le
voir sur le terrain il va alors le match
retour et c'est vrai que là on a envie
c'est on avait envie que kilian et karim
bris hier soir peut-être que karim rire
a en tout cas dont dans quinze jours